Cassava is a really important crop. It
provides for over 500 million Africans
every day. When all other crops fail
farmers know that they could rely on
their Cassava plants to provide them
food.
"One of my biggest challenges for the Cassava is diseases."
There are several diseases that affect Cassava and these diseases makes the roots inedible.
It is very crucial to actually
control and manage these diseases.
So we're trying to use machine learning to
respond to those diseases and Tensorflow
is the best foundation for our solutions.
The app that we've designed can
diagnose multiple diseases.
It's called Nuru, Swahili for "light" -
the light that farmers can use to
see their problems and find solutions.
You wave your phone over a specific
leaf, look at it, and if it has a symptom
a box will pop up saying you have this
problem. When you get a diagnosis we have
an option for you to get advice and
learn about the best management
practices. The object detection that we
use through Tensorflow relies upon our team
annotating images we've collected over
5,000 high quality images of different
Cassava diseases for this project. We
use a single shot detector model on a
mobile net architecture it's able to
make predictions in less than one second.
Instead of having to implement thousands of lines of code, Tensorflow
provides a library of functions that allow us to build architectures in much less time.
We need something that can be deployed on a phone without any connection.
Tensorflow is able to shrink these mural networks to be able to fit on your mobile device.
The human input is absolutely critical.
We're really building something
that augments your experience and makes you better at your job so with AI tools
and machine learning you can
improve the yields, you can protect your
crops, and you can have a much more
reliable source of food.
AI offers the prospect to fundamentally
transform the life of hundreds of
millions of farms around the world. "I have seen for myself how the technology works to detect diseases."
You can see a product that can actually
make someone's life better.
This is a kind of revolution.